thank you so much it's an honor to be
here
tonight the office of strategic Ser
Services is a league of extrordinary men
and women and I had the privilege and
honor of interviewing about 600 of those
men and women over the course of the
last 25 years I've interviewed about
4,000 World War II veterans and Veterans
of other Wars including Korea and Modern
Warfare but one of the toughest
interviews the toughest people that I
ever met was an OSS veteran and his name
was Howard wheeler
chapel and Chapel was extraordinary and
every time I would try to go interview
him he would say well Pat you just have
to come out here and it was kind of a
throw lightway line he never wanted to
talk to me finally I cornered his case
officer during World War II his nickname
was the brain and the brain was a guy by
the name of Albert Marazzi who ran the
Italian section of the oper the
operational groups in Northern Italy
these were were 15 16 man teams that
were dropped behind the lines in the
most dangerous part of Nazi Germany and
they had to survive against the
SS and the brain was good friends with
chapel and uh sort of knew what to say
and when I whenever I would go over the
brain's house we'd go to his basement
and he had massive filing cabinets of
all these World War II files that had
only been recently
Declassified most of the OSS story had
been hidden and Declassified until the '
80s and '90s and some of it still is but
he talked to Chapel and he said to him
talk to this guy and Howard I called him
up when I got to San Francisco and I
said Howard I'd like to talk to you he's
like well you have to come out here I'm
like I'm
here and he just and then I had the
brain column as sort of like the
reinforcement and he said to me after
the second call Pat meet me at the gas
station the Shell station at spy glass
Hill Drive at noon
tomorrow no problem I got there at
exactly
11:55 a large Lincoln Continental dark
you know dark blue pulls up guy with
sort of sunglasses window rolls down
it's like O'Donnell yep follow me went
back to his
house and uh he's like you need to go to
the bathroom or anything it was
immediate intimidation
tactics pulls out his Fairburn syes
fighting knife which he carried during
World War II starts opening up the
male has his his nails that are like
count
chocula and he you know they're long
he's picking his nails with the the the
dagger and I said to him Howard do you
remember remember the man that you
killed at the bushy
Bridge it's like yeah I don't know if I
killed him with a ski pole or a silenc
pistol I'm like I knew right away we're
going back to the war and that's what we
did we started to talk about World War
II and his mission behind the lines and
it was extraordinary his first one you
know he's in the middle of it's in the
middle of Northern Italy in the middle
of nowhere and it's right after
Christmas January time frame
and the SS had pulled off a entire
Battalion off the line to do what's
known as a ramento and they would flush
out any of the partisans or the OSS
operatives that were there small team
which was headed by
chapel and the entire Countryside was
swept with SS men with machine guns and
dogs and his team was flushed out of
their safe house and he operated what
was known as a Browning automatic rifle
as he was peppering the SS that were
trying to overrun his house he was
running for his life and these men were
running down a stream that was
frozen and they were being chased by the
SS and dogs several of the men literally
hid in small cubby holes in side of the
stream and covered themselves in mud as
the SS were trying to find them and in
one situation one of the SS operatives
literally they they poked a bayet into
the hole and and the man grabbed the the
bayet the rifle with his bare hands and
the guy tried to pull it back and he let
go at that point he pounced on him and
killed him with a
knife Howard was then pursued by an SS
group and was
captured and it was there that I asked
him about one of his one of his
incidents I said
what what happened when you pulled out
he had a 40 he had a ballpoint pen that
actually doubled as a 22 caliber pistol
and he pulled out the pen and the guy
was like what the Yeah it's like almost
like what the hell and he fired his his
Mouser rifle as as Howard was running
away like a racehorse and it grazed the
back of his shin and I said do you still
have that scar he pulled up his leg and
the scar was there and that was kind of
the beginning of his his experience
there but it was also the story of some
of these extraordinary men and women who
were the OS
the office of strategic Services begins
its story in
1941 in another name by something called
the coordinator of
information in 1941 in the summer of
1941 the United States didn't have a
centralized intelligence service nor did
it have Special Operations forces none
of this stuff existed at the
time and just prior to that the the
existence of the coordinator of
information it's quite an interesting
story The the writer of James Bond
novels Ian Fleming and another guy by
the name of Admiral Godfrey came to the
United States to ostensibly talk about
Port security when in reality they were
there to urge President Roosevelt to
create a centralized type of an
intelligence agency along with Special
Operations forces and Fleming
handed William
Donovan a two-page document which was
kind of a shell of what this
organization might look like Donovan
took some of those ideas but also
created his own organization and with an
executive order the coordinator
coordinator of information was born and
with it also Special Operations forces
and Donovan didn't look really
necessarily at the British but he looked
back at America's own legacy which is
rich in Special Operation history but he
wasn't looking back in World War I
because Special Operations didn't exist
there he looked all the way back to the
Civil War and he was looking back at a
group called The Jesse Scouts and
Mosby's Rangers and the Confederate
Secret Service and others and that is
sort of the Genesis of of American
Special Operations forces but the
organization itself is layered in
multiple
departments and I'll sort of give you a
little bit of a thumbnail of what they
are and then drill down into a couple of
and then get into some of the missions
themselves which are really unique and
and interesting the first part of the
OSS that's very unique for a military
intelligence organization at the time
was something called the research and
Analysis division or branch and this was
groundbreaking for its time the British
themselves didn't even have it which
were considered um by far sort of the
gold standard in intelligence at the
time what they had is RNA leaned on
Donovan's experience and all about let
me just sort of back up a second William
Donovan was one of the most decorated
soldiers in World War I he received the
distinguished service cross and the
Medal of Honor for his ballor in the
69th Division and then he was an
extremely successful lawyer on Wall
Street and he was also very active in
the Republican Party he was a um
campaign chair many things at that time
but Roosevelt leaned on Donovan for his
experience and his Valor and his just
smarts and his contacts to create this
organization and he has to come up with
all of the things that are needed and
one of the things he comes up with is is
the research and Analysis division which
is he takes the best professors in the
United States to specialize in things
that are related to the war effort and
he brings them into the OSS this is kind
of the chairborne division a or 900 of
the greatest Scholars on history of
Poland Romania
whatever Logistics in Europe and all
these great minds are put together to
analyze things they're analyzing the raw
data that the agents are getting they're
bringing in but they're also doing
things like
analyzing the objectives that bombers
need to to to take or to on on on
Targets in Nazi Germany which in itself
was fairly novel there was an an enemy
objectives unit which was looking at the
oil production of the Third Reich and
where those critical choke points were
those nerve centers and where to bomb
which they were highly successful at
they also looked at something as mundane
as a serial number on a tank and if you
have if you ever had a Luger Pistol you
know that every single part on that
pistol is is numbered with a serial
number number tanks are similar in the
German army during World War II through
those serial numbers they were able to
Divine when the tank was made and then
part of the order of battle of where it
was placed in North Africa or wherever
it was fighting so with these little
mundane tidbits of information they were
able to piece together entire Mosaic of
intelligence so moving along within sort
of this umbrella of the OSS or
coordinator of information at this time
you have another interesting unit or
branch called the research and
development Branch this is Q's
laboratory and um a guy by the name of
Stanley Lovel who's kind of a mad
scientist runs it and they develop all
kinds of fascinating and important
weapons of war that will be used in
spycraft everything from a the 22
caliber pen pistol that I that Howard
used to a piece of exploding coal that
somebody can throw a a coal tener can
throw into a furnace in a in a
locomotive to blow it Skyhigh to Limpet
mines to something called the Joan
Eleanor which was a a walkie-talkie type
device that allowed an agent on the
ground to talk to a
mosquito um British airplane in the air
and this becomes the technology behind
cell phones Mini many years
later they had something called the Java
Man which allowed a television set to be
inserted into a guided missile and guide
the
missile and then it gets into some of
the more wacky stuff and I'll never
forget I spent literally 20 years at the
National Archives mining the archives to
write effectively five books on the
office of strategic
services and the archives it's kind of
like like drilling for oil sometimes you
get lucky and then sometimes you don't
and one day I'll never forget I found a
file that was had a rusted little paper
clip and it said the truth
drug I'm like oh this ought to be
interesting and it talked about a
detective from New York City that was
testing a specialized drug that the OSS
R&D uh Branch had developed to make
people talk and and they used um the
Main Ingredients was uh uh
TCH which was I mean basically behind
cannabis and they look put it in a
liquid
form and uh injected it into cigarettes
and other things and the man that they
used was this detective from New York
City and he tested it on a man who was a
known mobster and I'll never forget I'm
reading this thing and it says he
spilled the
beans
and and they talked about all the things
that he revealed in their conversation
which he didn't know he was doing which
was illegal but it's still a very
fascinating story behind some of the
things that the OSS was
doing um moving along they have
something called the morale operations
unit which is psychological warfare
which at the time was
groundbreaking and this is everything
from radios that were broadcasting to
you know all of Europe where they would
they brought in Marina dayrick for
instance to broadcast a German troops uh
propaganda that were part of the you
know Pro Allied propaganda to something
called operation
sauerkraut and this is a fascinating
story well I'll never forget I I
interviewed 70s something Barbara LS at
this time and she she was just a a
beautiful lady that talked about how she
would go into prisoner of war cages to
interview people for her Mission
sauerkraut and they went in there and
they tried to find people that were
against the Nazi effort and what they
were doing was they were getting them to
take propaganda and disseminate it
behind the lines these former German
soldiers and in some case and they did
do that and it was
effective you know other things are are
pretty wild and novel uh operation
cornflakes for instance they took they
wanted to
infiltrate the German reiches mail
system and what they did is they they
came up with maual the same mail bag
that The Reich post office used and then
they put letters in there that were
propaganda and address to German
residents real addresses
and they infiltrated that through either
agents or then remarkably they would
find out when the timetable was for
trains that were carrying German mail
literally strafe the train and then some
of the planes that were strafing the
train also bombed instead of bombs
mailbags filled with this fake
mail